bonjour par l'arrêt baisse mais aussi de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france
comment est-ce que vous accueillez ce
retour de saad hariri au poste de
premier ministre
comment faire du neuf avec du vieux
voilà on est tous dubitatif parce que
vous savez bien quand on a passé par
deux échecs il a quand même foire et toi
gouvernement je ne vois pas comment il
peut réussir celui ci sait comment
chimie
quand vous avez une expérience qui ne
fonctionne pas ou ne la refait pas vous
changez les ingrédients est justement là
il parle de former un gouvernement
composé je cite d'experts sans attache
partisane
donc selon vous c'est utopique ce n'est
pas réaliste bien sûr que ce n'est pas
réaliste parce que comme vous avez
bienvenu après l'intervention du
président macron nous avons bien vu
qu'ils sont en train de se partager le
gâteau ils se sont divisés les postes ça
fait un mois et demi qui sont en train
de se réunir ouvertement ou pas mais ils
sont en train de se moquer de nous
encore une fois pour avoir les aides
une façon pour nous en tant que libanais
quelqu'un qui a été autant mêler à des
dossiers de corruption tant dans
différents ministères qu'à la
municipalité de beyrouth ne peut en
aucun cas être la personne qui peut
sortir le pays de cette catastrophe
financière et économique
ils sont dus à leur pillage et à leur
corruption vous venez de parler de la
france d'hariri s'engage à un des
réformes en adéquation avec le site
l'initiative française
quelles rues de paris selon vont en
coulisses et est-ce qu'il n'ya pas une
contradiction entre cette nomination et
les déclarations récentes des manuels
macron ces dernières semaines écoutez
ils nous font croire que monsieur macro
est derrière tout cela
comme le président macro ne nous a rien
dit je préfère penser que c'est du de
l'enfumage
tant qu'on n'a pas eu un son clair net
et précis du président macron pour le
moment on a l'impression qu'ils ont fait
tout ce set 7/4
cette pâte à malaxe qu'ils ont malaxer
cette pâte pour que l'on dit le service
et qu'il il sait les trois personnages
aux pouvoirs qui dirige le liban hariri
maintenant comme vous a vu la célèbre
photo officielle il ya berry qui est le
président du parlement et
le président ajoute le président du
liban est ce que vous dénoncez
du coup un verrouillage du système
politique c'est ça bien sûr ils n'ont
pas consulté la société civile vous
savez qu'il ya des gens très validant la
société civile au liban nous avons des
experts qualifiés
personne ne les a consultés ils font
leur petite cuisine de côté avec les
mêmes gens qu'ils recyclent la nièce de
l'un la fiancée de l'autre la copine de
l'un ça marche comme ça avec on l'a bien
vu pendant 30 ans saad hariri a été
désigné car soutenue par une courte
majorité de députés en quoi cette faible
marge de manoeuvre peut-il le fragiliser
à moyen terme
côté pour le moment il faut des jarres
et qu'il est face à un gouvernement on
est tous dubitatif c'est pour ça les
gens et hier n'ont pas descendu ne sont
pas descendus dans la rue manifester ils
ont préféré attendre on va voir
qu'est-ce qui va choisir qui va être le
personnage qui va accepter
à ce moment on verra bien la rue qu'est
ce qu'elle va donner
justement est ce que la révolution peut
reprendre au liban sous quelle forme et
quand exactement
et nous avons plein de gens nous avons
déjà organisé plusieurs colloques nous
avons des alliances entre plusieurs
groupes de révolutionnaire le souci que
comme nous sommes dans un pays qui est
en train d'appliquer de nouveau la
répression de la liberté d'expression
donc nous préférons garder ces gens là
un petit peu de côté parce que les
attentats dans le moyen-orient ses
légions vous savez bien
donc ces gens là où ils sont en train de
faire des programmes politiques des
programmes pour redresser le liban et je
pense d'ici quelques semaines
ça va se décanter honorât des programmes
et des noms à pour pouvoir les élire
dans les prochaines élections
très rapidement pour revenir sur la
nomination de saad hariri
quelle est la cote de popularité du
premier ministre
lui qui avait démissionné on le rappelle
il ya un mois il y a un an
il ya un an il a démissionné août et sa
cote de popularité est uniquement dans
les quartiers c'est horrible a dit
mais c'est dans les quartiers sunnites
qui sont les quartiers les plus pauvres
owni banc le nord du liban à carhaix
teint est une zone on peut dire c'est un
département s'unit d'une pauvreté
extrême toutes les ong peuvent pouvoir
compter l'horreur qui se passe là bas
mais ils ont toujours espoir parce qu'il
ya quelques années il avait promis au
peuple libanais neuf cent mille emplois
donc pour le moment on n'a rien vu même
pas un
donc ces gens là il dit dans l'espoir et
ils vivent dans vous savez le sectarisme
c'est quelque chose d'abominable de
d'appâter les gens par le côté sectaire
et religieux c'est quelque chose de
d'abject on est en 2020 on doit pouvoir
dépasser tout cela merci merci pour la
réponse d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes activistes
politiques et membres du mouvement
beyrouth madinaty littéralement en
français mais route ma ville